hey i'm alex i'm the tasty producer
behind this video for cheesy taquitos or
as i like to call them chiquitos
[Music]
stay tuned to the end of the video for
some producer tips
so i know these aren't your typical
taquitos but trust me they're so
delicious you really can't go wrong with
crispy cheese
[Music]
so we all know how important seasoning
is and for this recipe i wanted to keep
it all pretty classic but still pack in
a lot of flavor but feel free to use
whatever seasonings you like you can
also adjust the spice level if you want
[Music]
i decided to show a chicken and a beef
version just to show that you can have
variety with these i mean you could even
take out the filling all together the
crispy cheese was good enough on its own
so for my t shell mixture i used two
cups parmesan and one cup mexican blend
cheese and that's because the parmesan
has less moisture and it'll give you the
structure you need to create the shell
when you take the cheese shell off of
the heat you're going to want to roll
them pretty quickly the melted cheese on
the inside is gonna help create that
seal and also if the cheese hardens
it'll crack when you roll it
i know these don't seem particularly
healthy but they are low carb so
there's that
so for garnish i added some fresh lime
juice some sour cream and some chopped
cilantro because i felt it really
brought the dish together but feel free
to play around with your favorite
toppings
so that's it i hope you enjoyed my video
and i hope you go try this recipe
yourself i think i ate like six of them
myself they were truly a killer
killer
die
uh
[Music]
you